- [Instructor] In this video,
we're gonna talk about
the greenhouse effect
and also the greenhouse gases,
which cause the greenhouse effect.
Now let's just start with a basic idea.
Imagine if earth had no
atmosphere, what would happen?
Well, you have the sun,
which is on average,
93 million miles away.
It's sending electromagnetic radiation
our way to the surface of the earth.
We're actually getting a
very, very small fraction
of the total electromagnetic
radiation of the sun.
And then that would heat up
the surface of the earth.
Now, what I have always found mind-blowing
is anything with temperature
will emit electromagnetic radiation.
And so it's emitting some of that energy,
it's losing some of that energy
to electromagnetic radiation.
So the surface would be releasing that
and it would go out into space.
But now let's introduce
the idea of an atmosphere.
And in particular, we're gonna think
about our lower atmosphere,
which starts at the surface and goes up
to about five to nine miles in altitude,
often known as the troposphere.
Now the troposphere has molecules in it,
has gases in it like carbon dioxide,
like water vapor, like methane.
Others include nitrous oxide
and chlorofluorocarbons.
You don't have to know
the chemical formula
of all of these things,
but what's interesting about these gases
that are in the lower atmosphere
is that they can absorb
some of those electromagnetic waves
that the surface of the earth is emitting.
So some of that energy
will make it out to space,
but some of that energy
will then be absorbed
by these molecules, by these gases,
and then they will emit
some of that back to earth.
And so that's why it's
called a greenhouse effect
because of all of that energy
that might have been sent out to space
if you didn't have an
atmosphere, not all of it is.
Some of it is reabsorbed
by the atmosphere,
which then sends it
back down to the surface
and that process can go on and on and on.
You can imagine that it's
trapping some of the energy.
Now, the greenhouse effect
and greenhouse gases,
the ones that I just listed,
they're oftentimes associated
with man-made climate
change and global warming.
And they are, for good reason,
but it's important to realize
that we actually need some
base level greenhouse effect
just for earth to be habitable
in the way that it is.
Without greenhouse gases, earth's surface
would be about negative
18 degrees Celsius,
which is the same as
zero degrees Fahrenheit,
which I think most of
y'all would recognize
is very, very, very cold
relative to what the actual averages are,
which are 15 degrees Celsius
or 59 degrees Fahrenheit.
And of course, these are
average temperatures,
but 59 is a nice refreshing brisk day,
not a frigid day like
zero degrees Fahrenheit.
And of course, these are averages.
It fluctuates around this on
time of year and where you are.
But this has makes it clear
that we do need these greenhouse gases
to keep the earth reasonably warm.
Now, the problem is,
is if the concentration
of these greenhouse gases
go out of equilibrium,
become unusually high,
and it does look like
that is indeed happening.
This right over here is a chart,
and the way that we're
able to figure that out
is by taking ice samples and rock samples
and looking into our past
or the geologic record
of how much carbon dioxide there has been
over the last 800,000 years.
And 800,000 years is a
very long time period.
Modern human beings have only been around
for 200,000 or 300,000 years.
And what you can see is the
concentration of carbon dioxide
has roughly fluctuated between
about 200 parts per million
and about 300 parts per million,
at least over the duration of this chart.
But in recent times, we've
gone well beyond that.
We've almost gone double
that average right over here.
And this is actually the highest levels
we've seen in three million years.
That's important to
realize that carbon dioxide
makes up a small percentage
of our atmosphere.
In fact, all of these greenhouse gases
make up a small percentage.
78% of the troposphere is
in nitrogen, 21% is oxygen.
The last 1% is things like argon,
water vapor, carbon dioxide, methane.
So even this small amount,
when the concentration
increases dramatically
can have a huge effect.
Now you might say, "Hey,
we were at these levels
three million years ago roughly,
maybe this is just some type of cycle
that we're seeing on earth."
And to recognize it,
this is indeed manmade,
we just have to look at a chart like this.
This tells us two things.
This tells us annual
emissions in this blue line,
this blue curve, and
then the total emission
or the total concentration
in the atmosphere,
because about one of the
things about greenhouse gas
like carbon dioxide, when it's emitted,
it doesn't just disappear.
And we can see if we go to
the pre-industrial revolution
or the early stages of
the industrial revolution,
CO2 emissions were pretty
low, pretty close to zero,
at least on this scale right over here.
There might've been some
basic CO2 emissions,
people had fires and stoves
and things like that.
But then as the industrial
revolution came into play
and we started using
fossil fuels more and more
to fuel transportation and
factories and other things,
our emissions have gone up dramatically.
And this coincides with
the total concentration
going well above that
800,000 year average.
So it's important to keep in
mind, the greenhouse effect
is needed to some degree,
but the problem is,
is when the concentration
of greenhouse gases
like carbon dioxide go well
beyond their historic averages,
which can over time warm the earth
and even a few degrees
centigrade of warming the earth
can have huge consequences
on our environment
and on our weather.
I'll throw out one last
idea just for kicks
because even though it's
called the greenhouse effect,
it's actually not how
actual greenhouses work.
The greenhouse effect,
as we just described it,
is really based on this idea that things
are getting the infrared radiation.
The electromagnetic radiation
is getting reabsorbed,
which then gets reemitted
back to the surface
and vice right versa.
In a real greenhouse,
you can imagine that it
is made out of glass.
What's happening is the
sunlight can come in
and it's warming the surface
and it's warming the air
inside the greenhouse,
and then that air is not
allowed to circulate.
So if the greenhouse had a little hole
at the top right over here,
that hot air would be allowed to go out
and circulate with the cool air up here,
but the air isn't allowed to mix,
and so the air gets hotter
and hotter and hotter.
It actually turns out that the glass
can let the electromagnetic radiation out
unlike greenhouse gases.
So it is a different
actual physical process,
but you can see where people
try to create the metaphor.